wo ich mir auch neues mikrofon kaufen
werde weil das ist jetzt völlig dagegen
schlagen hey leute herzlich willkommen
zum ersten kontakt hier auf meinem kanal
wo ich immer am sonntag hier januar live
video hochladen werde wo ich über dinge
quatsch beziehungsweise einfach
irgendwelche sachen zeige wenn ich
irgendwie unter der woche unterwegs war
oder wohin gott also ich hab gerade so
gemacht und ist kam irgendwie total
wasserfontäne draußen direkt auf die
kamera musste erst mal kurz deswegen
linse ich hoffe die geht es wieder gut
jedenfalls was ich sagen wollte in
diesem ersten kontakt der noch immer
kein richtiger kontakt ist weil ich euch
immer noch fahren wollte was ihr euch so
wünscht alles und zwar könnt ihr wieder
sachen die kommentare schreiben wie
beispielsweise du hast ja mal ein video
gemacht also das habe ich schon gelesen
so was wie ja du hast ja mal ein video
gemacht 20 dinge die du magst macht mal
20 l 20 dinge die du hast machte man
video 20 dinge die du mark oder ihr
könnt mir zum beispiel auch immer auf
meiner facebook-seite oder auch hier in
den kommentaren immer fragen stellen mit
den kommentaren hier ist ein bisschen
komisch mit google+ geworden die fragen
stellen zu mir damals ein effekt dass er
so oder so einem tag heißt es glaube ich
hole mir verschiedene sachen fragt wo
ihr mich verschiedene sachen fragen
könnt und ich gehe dann darauf ein das
kann alles mögliche verschiedener sein
dann wollte ich auch auf jeden fall wenn
der erste schnee fällt wollte ich mir
direkt meine kamera schnappen und auch
draußen garten laufen und direkten video
machen wie ich dann im schnee herum
sitzen und mitspieler also wo ich
einfach so sein wiederkommen ich weiß
ich hätte dir darauf bock ist wie ich
dann auch am kontakt manchmal hochladen
irgendwie sowas will ich da mal draußen
bin oder auch hab ich mir auch überlegt
dass wenn ich irgendwie in der woche
unterwegs bin wenn ich irgendwie dieser
wenn ich joggen bin oder sei es
irgendwie wenn ich irgendwo weil sie
nicht auf einem spielplatz wird werde
ich dann irgendwann sein sollte oder auf
dem rückweg von der schule oder wenn ich
mal nachts im wald bin und nach hause
fahre oder ihm gesagt dass ich dann
einfach mein handy raus holen dann
irgendwie filme und das dann einfach
hier mit rein schneider-ammanns ende
also was haltet ihr davon halten ich
finde das eine ganz gute idee wenn ich
so über die woche war so ein bisschen
filme irgendwie wenn ich morgens zur
schule fahren egal ob handy rausholen
halte ich bin euer weg zur schule dann
immer so im kontakt erfahrt ihr dann was
ich die komplette woche wahr gemacht
habe aber es kann natürlich auch mal
sowas sein das ist dann wirklich einfach
so ein video machen wo ich einfach meine
meinung zu dem thema äußern
es kann nicht alles sein von mir und es
kann
jetzt kommen die ihr seid jetzt gefragt
und ihr könnt mir das in die kommentare
schreiben hier was ich hier genau machen
soll
ich bin noch ein bisschen erkältet und
ich hab hier ist also ich muss
eigentlich ein schal tragen weil mein
kompletter hat ist an meiner stimme die
es total im eimer das liegt nicht an die
mikrofone wo ich war auch einmal das
mikrofon kaufen werde weil das ist aber
jetzt habe ich dagegen geschlagen das
hängt einfach so runter das mikro sonst
so wenn hier die kamera fängt hier wird
das mikro drauf und das mikro ist
einfach so das hängt einfach so nehmen
weil diese gummibällen die dass ihr
festhalten sind einfach abgegangen
deswegen ich werde noch mal hingeht und
da ein bisschen auf den tisch hauen dass
die mir da neues geben und dann würde
ich sagen geht's eigentlich schon direkt
nächste woche los mit dem ersten kontakt
ihr dürft bestimmen was ich da mache und
ob ich das machen soll dass ich da am
ende vielleicht ein paar zähne rein
packe die ich zu über die woche noch mal
so gemacht habe dann würde ich sagen
wenn ich meine gute besserung dass meine
stimme möglichst schnell wieder da ist
und dass ich nicht komplett meine stimme
verliere und dann gucke ich jetzt yoko
gegen claassen um die welt weiter